don't feel too badly for lala land
it won six Oscars the most of any movie
this year
[Music]
la la la la land am a stone to my mom
and my dad and my brother Spencer and my
whole family I love you so much
the Best Actress winner gave shoutouts
to book her brother who was her date and
to her leading man Ryan Gosling thank
you for making me laugh and for always
raising the bar and for being the
greatest partner on this crazy adventure
backstage Emma cried when greeted by
last year's Best Actress winner brie
Larson now 28 years old she was young
Emily stone who left Arizona at age 15
to pursue her dream in Hollywood we
caught her jumping for joy backstage as
the film began to rake in Oscars
including one for Damien Chazelle at 32
the youngest Best Director ever I'm
frankly feeling nothing is that so Ryan
Gosling didn't win Best Actor but he may
have gotten the most camera time of the
night it began with a hug from Justin
Timberlake his old Mickey Mouse Club
castmate his date was sister Nandi
instead of Ava Mendes the mother of his
two young daughters and through all the
dramas Riley best picture afterwards
Emma kept her sense of humor this is a
statue of a naked man
you